i'm max tegmark and it's a great honor
to welcome you all to the 2020 future of
life awards where we're going to
celebrate two amazing people who've
helped save about 200
million lives
and to help us celebrate we're gonna
hear from
a bunch of fascinating people from bill
gates we're gonna we're gonna hear from
anthony fauci
jennifer doudna
this award that we're giving out
you might think what's another award
there's so many awards you can win the
oscars for making great movies you can
win
medals for running really fast
you can win nobel prizes for doing great
science in fact
we have someone who has done just that
yesterday who's with us today
why do we need another one well
we feel that there should also be an
award for those unsung heroes who have
done incredibly great things for
humanity but many people haven't heard
of or much less famous
than your average hollywood actor
to give you a flavor of this let me tell
you who's won so far
and 2017
the future of life award went to vasily
arkhipov
who single-handedly prevented a soviet
nuclear nuclear attack
on u.s forces
and we're so honored to have his very
own daughter yelena with us live today
from moscow please elena and a warm
welcome to you
if it weren't for your father we
probably would not be here
that was a tough fact to follow but the
following year
stanislav petrov got the future life
award for helping avert another nuclear
war in
1983
when the soviet early warning center
that he was in charge of saw five
incoming american nuclear missiles
and
we're very grateful that he was the guy
in charge that day
the following year
the award went to professor matthew
meselson just down the road from where i
am here at mit down at harvard
for
his incredible contributions to uh
getting biological weapons banned and
for avoiding an arms race in bioweapons
and this is why today we think of
biology as a force for good for
developing covad vaccines and for
saving lives rather than for taking
lives
many of my friends got really worried
about this and said hey
you've set impossible standards for the
future life award this is just an
impossible act to follow
but i'm really delighted that today
we are going to prove them wrong by
introducing you to two other
truly truly
worthy winners so
let's roll the video
[Applause]
imagine how you'd react to the headline
mutated coronavirus discovered killing
30 percent of those infected
smallpox was such a lethal virus
estimated to have killed 500 million
people in its last century
but a massive international team effort
defeated smallpox completely eradicating
it and unicef estimates that this has
saved close to 200 million lives so far
today to celebrate the 41st anniversary
of the official eradication of smallpox
we grant the future of life award to two
heroes who critically contributed to
this victory
bill feige and victor zhanov
viktor's donov has been called the best
person who ever lived by oxford
professor will mccaskill for
successfully persuading the world health
organization to initiate an eradication
campaign where the united states and the
soviet union teamed up despite the cold
war
while serving as the soviet union's
deputy minister of health
victor's dhanov persuaded naysayers both
at home and abroad
that the world could and should
eradicate smallpox with a united effort
and arranged for the soviet union to
donate 25 million doses of smallpox
vaccine to kick-start the effort in
developing countries
the world health organization accepted
his proposal in 1959
and he lived to see smallpox officially
eradicated in 1979
he passed away in 1987 and his award
will be received by his sons victor
janov and michael brukinski in his
memory
eradicating smallpox required not only
audacity but also solving the problem of
insufficient resources for vaccinating
everyone
while working for the center of disease
control in africa as chief of the
smallpox eradication program
bill fakie developed a highly successful
surveillance and ring vaccination
strategy which has been described as
applying water to the house on fire
rather than the whole neighborhood
this greatly reduced the number of
vaccinations needed ensuring that the
limited resources available suffice to
make smallpox the first infectious
disease to be eradicated in human
history
bill feige and victor donov are true
heroes
who remind us of the power of science
and international collaboration for
tackling covet 19
and future health challenges
thank you both
yes
thank you both i'm tearing up here
because it's so moving what what you
have accomplished
if there were a nobel prize for saving
lives
you would both have won it and and so
would vasily archipela
stanley stanislav petrov and matthew
messelson and if it were not for the
collective
acts of all of you
i would probably not be alive right now
and the same probably goes for most of
you listening to this so it's a really
great honor to get to bestow the future
life award today to
dr bill fagey and dr viktor stanov
thanks to the amazing generosity of jan
talin
one of the founders of the future of
life institute
you will be sharing a hundred thousand
dollars
and also it is my great honor
to give you something personal right now
to hold on to
so
it's a great honor for me to first of
all give that 2020
future of life a word
to
dr bill fagey
see our little mit
particle transmutator through space time
worked
congratulations
can you unmute bill feige they are
producers
or maybe we're on it we got it
congratulations
so thank you max for the honor for the
plaque and for the exceptional science
that allowed you to
transmit this to me thank you very much
our pleasure
and it is
similarly an enormous honor to give the
future of life award to the late viktor
zdanov and we're so delighted to have
you here
dr michael buclinski
to receive this plaque
oh this one went inside it's it's hard
to pull it off the internet actually
but uh
thank you so much max and it's a great
honor
and we and finally the third plaque
it's a great honor
to get
to give it to to give this to dr victor
stone of junior
amazing what some quantum teleportation
can do congratulations all yeah thank
you very much i'm very proud of it thank
you
and we are very proud
max we uh lost your audio max we lost
your audio
go ahead and speak
again can you hear me now yes we can
hear you now all right
so congratulations again we now turn to
celebrating
our winners
and first let's hear from bill gates
i'm sorry i can't be with you to honor
two true heroes of global health
victor zadonov and bill faye
with the future of life award
they're phenomenal examples of what it
means to harness science for public
health
the eradication of smallpox not only
prevented unnecessary suffering and
death it showed the world that diseases
can be defeated
and it reminds us of the need for global
cooperation and fighting other diseases
such as covenanting malaria polio and
diseases we have yet to encounter
i've never had the pleasure of meeting
dr donov but the more i learn about his
accomplishments the more i respect his
work
he played a leading role in getting
rival superpowers to team up against
smallpox
i do have the pleasure of knowing bill
faye
it's fair to say he was my first teacher
in global health
bill was one of the first people melinda
and i turned to when we began learning
about the subject
and he's had a huge influence on us
we wanted to understand what it took to
eradicate diseases so we turned to one
of the people who'd had actually done it
he gave me a list of about 80 books and
journals to read and i looked at all of
them
one important thing i learned from that
assignment was how much more i needed to
learn
luckily bill has been there as helping
us every step of the way
also sharing his knowledge wisdom and
passion he also has more memorable
quotes from ancient writers than any
other person i know
bill has set a phenomenal example for
everyone who cares about global health
as a physician teacher leader and
advocate for acting on the idea that all
lives have equal value
congratulations again to bill
and to the family of dr sadanov
and thank you all for your continuing
efforts to save lives around the world
yes thank you from all of us
and to continue the the celebrations uh
we're now going to turn to a fun
discussion with uh dr jennifer du doudna
and dr anthony fauci
and
first of all
is it okay if i called you simply
jennifer and tony
good good so my first question to you
jennifer is
what was in how did you guys pull off
the
the nobel prize ceremony yesterday
without uh upsetting um
tony with poor social distancing
well it went through a few different
planning stages and ended up happening
outdoors on my patio in berkeley
california
and
i think uh everybody here would be
pleased to know that it was a a lovely
event very small very safe everybody
masked and distanced
but still really meaningful i think to
all of us as a celebration of science
so we're all looking nervously at you
tony uh do you approve
oh absolutely
[Laughter]
yes i mean uh given the circumstances in
which the world is right now
um the kind of honor that was given to
jennifer for her extraordinary
scientific accomplishment could not be
put off so
in the spirit of improvisation
what they did was to do it in a way that
was totally safe but nonetheless
extraordinarily meaningful so she gets
an a plus for public health wonderful
huge congratulations to you jennifer not
only on winning the nobel prize that was
the easy part but for getting an a plus
from tony fauci
so let me first ask each of you maybe
you can you can start jennifer
if there's anything you want any
congratulations that you want to pass
along
to the winners
well i i certainly
uh i certainly am in awe of your work
it's extraordinary
i think that you know the the example of
the smallpox eradication effort is one
that we all look to as a model for what
can be achieved in in global public
health it's truly amazing
and boy it couldn't be more relevant
this year in 2020 when we find ourselves
in the middle
of a global pandemic and i hope on the
verge of eradicating that virus that's
causing it the cyrus cov2 virus
with emerging vaccines and i hope we get
into a little bit of a discussion about
that because i think it's a it's a
really exciting
opportunity we have in front of us but
also a really big challenge
great
so what about you tony do you want to is
there anything particularly you want to
convey
to the to the winners or about them yeah
well thank you max well
you know as a person who's been
involved in infectious diseases now for
for several decades
um
uh i'm just thrilled to be here uh with
you today to pay honor
to victor and and bill
um i never met uh dr dzanov but um
bill feige has been a friend and an
inspiration not only to me
but to virtually every other
public health official
who has tackled any serious problem he's
become together with victor the gold
standards
of what is achievable i mean the the
massive undertaking
of taking one of the most devastating
diseases in the history
of civilization
and not only controlling it not only
eliminating it but actually eradicating
it
is really stands as the standard as
jennifer said
of what we hope to do with other
diseases with polio
with measles
and ultimately i hope
with saw's coronavirus too
so you set a high standard and hopefully
some of us will meet it in the future
wonderful
so
one
big question i have here is
reflecting on this triumph aside from
celebrating it is
what is it that we can learn from it
what lessons
did can we draw from these great
successes both the political ones of
viktor's donovan getting all this
international collaboration going
between rivaling superpowers
to do better global health and also on
the scientific side and in terms of the
management what lessons are that are
relevant today
for example
uh tony are there anything any lessons
here do you you feel are relevant to uh
fighting covet
well yes max you alluded a bit to a
couple of them i think one of the most
important
is when you're dealing with a global
health challenge you've got to attack it
at a global level
and what bill and what victor did
was to really establish that there are
no boundaries there are the globe that
we live on smallpox
was a disease that afflicted
society they teamed up in what appeared
at the time to be
divisive and competing superpowers
there's no secret
that we live in a divisive world right
now we live even in the country in which
we're all sitting right now at least
some of us in the united states is very
divisive and we're dealing with one of
the most historic outbreaks that have
occurred in the last 100 years dating
back to 1918 so there are many lessons
to be learned
that as enormous as the problem is
you can encounter it and you can
overcome it the way bill and victor did
despite the fact that politically you
were in very problematic circumstances
so i think it's almost eerily similar
when you talk about the differences of
what we're doing now and what bill and
victor did decades ago
yeah
feel free to chime in uh you too bill
and uh
you too michael if you have reflections
on this and what what we
should what we should learn from from
this if there's
yeah
anything
just wanted to say that um victor was
never awarded
any kind of uh prize or anything in the
soviet union for his accomplishments in
in eradicating smallpox that's amazing
and
the reason probably was that uh
smallpox at that time was not
such a
you know major uh
medical problem in in soviet union uh it
was a problem in in underdeveloped world
and that's that even makes it uh in my
view even more
kind of significant that victor at that
time
uh spent all his efforts and uh his uh
this was actually his lifelong efforts
to
engage international scientific uh
cooperation to fight this uh you know
problem
uh around the world
i'm so
delighted also to have so many
participants from around the world
making this a very international
celebration right now and and
what we just heard there about really
collaborating internationally and
including the developing world that
sounds very much like
you bill like what you spent so much of
your work doing do you want to comment
on on any of the lessons learned as well
in your mind
thank you max first uh jennifer
congratulations to you
and
it was a pleasure to have bill gates
make his statement because i've said
this many times
when the history of global health is
finally written
we'll find that the year 2000 was a
tipping point
and it was because of the gates family
getting involved in global health
and tony thank you so much for
uh being here
a friend of yours asked me if i would
find out what you've been doing this
last year and so maybe we could talk
about that later but in the meantime
let me just say that tony has turned out
to be
the
ultimate scientist
huxley once said that science is simply
common sense at its best
and tony has provided that every day
the common sense that it's best even
when there's a lot of
noise around this
untruths going around and so forth the
the other thing i'd like to say about
tony if i recall correctly tony
you were driving to your first day as an
infectious disease resident
when you heard on the radio
the surgeon general of the united states
declaring the end of infectious diseases
and you wonder what in the world am i
doing
it shows you the the problem with the
predictions
but the the question of of what have we
learned i think one of the single
biggest lessons that i learned
is that if you're going to do
not only the eradication of disease but
any
scientific endeavor there are three
things that have to come together one is
the science
and people outside of science think we
really know what's happening
but uh i'm reminded of the fact that
richard feynman said uncertainty
is the basis of science he said in fact
certainty is the achilles heel
of science
and
people see science as being truth but
it's actually just a way of finding
getting as close to certainty and as
close to truth as we can
and then when you look at the huxley
quote of
that it's common sense that it's best
that's one of the three things that one
has to uh to think about second
will durant said if you add art to
science
you now bring creativity into this so
you have creative common sense at its
best
and he used as his example immotep the
egyptian physician who was also an
artist who designed and built the step
pyramid
and then for the third part of this
i go back to roger bacon 700 years ago
who did a report for the pope
and he came out with three
summary statements but one of them was
science has no moral compass
therefore you need scientists with a
moral compass
and if you put this all together you're
talking about creative moral common
sense at its best and that's a great
foundation for any science endeavor
and that seems like a wonderful
description of both the viktor donovan
bill feige also that goes like a red
thread throughout their work
i've
very much enjoyed reading
reading bill's book which i would highly
recommend
anyone who wants to learn more about
smallpox eradication house on fire
and um
where you can see all these three things
and there is also a book that has never
been published in the english language
about
viktor zhdanov
which is written by his late wife so
to help honor him we have had it
translated now into english for the very
first time and on the award website
we're putting it there as a free pdf
download
absolutely fascinating reading where i
think again those very three traits that
you just mentioned there
shine through loud and clear as we'll
continue talking about later today at a
personal level also i i
almost teared up here when you talked
about how how the foundation of science
is not certainly but uncertainty because
and quoted my great physics here richard
feynman because when people ask me
sometimes to define science
to me it's all about
embracing uncertainty i
to me being a scientist really means
that i would rather have
questions
i can't answer than answers i can't
question and um
so
the
before we move on from from this
question about what lessons we learned
let me throw it out
to all four of you again uh jennifer
tony
michael build to see if there's anything
more you would like to add on this
fascinating topic
there are two things max that i would
add i think the second
lesson
is the lesson of tenacity
tenacity doesn't always win
but it's the only thing that does win
and when you think of victor
coming up with his idea in 1958 which
was presented
in minneapolis
most world health assemblies are held in
geneva
but this one was held in minneapolis so
he was doing it on u.s ground
proposing a smallpox eradication program
and he did that every year
at the world health assembly until
finally he was agreed to put some money
into it so tenacity is very important
the third lesson though would be
to actually learn the lessons
because i see tony every day
not only fighting coronavirus
but fighting people who are not
observing the lessons of the past what
we've learned which you need to know the
truth you need coalitions you need a
national plan you need to work globally
and so tony's been up against both
a virus
and
misconceptions on how to proceed with
the program
so it's a double task for him
so tony let me ask you what
lessons we should learn from you that
what is your secret how do you manage to
stay so true to these ideals of common
sense
compassionate science despite all sorts
of
pressures from all directions what can
you teach the rest of us
well i think it was just mentioned a
little bit ago
what i try to do is focus like a laser
beam
on what my purpose and what my end game
is and that is right now in the middle
of an outbreak
the health and the safety of the
american people
driven
by evidence-based
science i mean just what we've been
talking about
here today
that
science leads us
to the development of policies
that are directed to the preservation of
the health and the safety of the
american public everything else max
is noise and you've got to take it for
what it is
it's distracting
noise once you get caught up
in the distracting noise you get
diverted and distracted from what your
main goal is
so you've got to be able to focus and
just say to yourself
you know sometimes
this is offensive and you want to hit
back and sometimes somebody's insulting
you and
saying that you're crazy just put it
aside and
focus
and stay with the science and actually
it's not that complicated to do because
it's pretty clear
when you see data and truth that we're
talking about today
that leads you to the development of
policies
you make it sound so easy tony but we
all know that it's actually very hard to
not get distracted by the noise
especially when it's
personal ad hominem and
really
really really distracting noise do you
have any personal techniques you can
recommend to the rest of us for just
doing what you actually said and
retaining focus nonetheless
well i go back to one of my favorite
movies the godfather part one
where they said it's nothing personal
it's strictly business
don't take it personal
i have learned something great today
tony thank you so much for that
but it's still max it's worth mentioning
that
tony was able to remain
a public servant
while many people then became private
servants they started out as public
servants but they could not withstand
the pressure and they became private
servants
and we're all very grateful for that
so so let us
shift gears now from reflecting on
lessons from the past to
talking about the future
to me
one thing that stands out
about
the smallpox eradication aside from the
fact that it's already according to
estimates saved about 2
100 million lives and continues saying
living lives every year when
it passes without any deaths aside from
the sheer goodness of it another thing
that really stands out is the sheer
audacity of it
right that's why it was so remarkable
for example that that viktor zhanov was
able to nonetheless sell this and
persuade people to cry for this ultimate
moonshot and even
both the audacity of the science of
eradicating this horrible disease and
the audacity of thinking that you could
get the soviet union and the united
states to work together
on something during the cold war so
my question for the future looking to
the future is can we also be if we get
inspired by this audacity
what other truly audacious
public health goals for public health
for medical science are there out there
now
that you would like us to see
take on uh let me start maybe with you
jennifer
well i certainly think you know going
back to the example of the the uh
smallpox eradication
the goal of of uh vaccinating the world
against the coronavirus is a big one and
an immediate one that we're facing and i
do think that there's a there's a big
challenge ahead but it's also an
incredible opportunity and it's an
opportunity not only
in global public health but also in
education and and uh kind of furthering
the
you know the view that i think many of
us uh here certainly would share which
is was articulated beautifully by
uh tony fauci that you know that that uh
you know science you know is uh you know
we need to rely on evidence-based
science
as we make public health decisions not
on
not on speculation or fears or or uh
you know uh various various kinds of uh
made up uh imagine imagined uh stories
but but really on
the best evidence that we have right now
for
a circumstance we find ourselves in such
as this pandemic so i certainly think
that's that's an immediate goal and then
beyond that um you know i i personally
think that uh we're facing uh
another
i think equally
important uh you know or equally global
emergency if you think about the
challenge we face with with uh climate
change
and i you know you might say well wait a
minute does that what does that have to
do with medicine or public health i
think it has everything to do with it
and i'd really like to see all of us as
scientists uh think about how we're
going to
address this and use our our expertise
and our work to do what we can
to deal with i think what is is truly an
existential threat to to all of us
those are very good points
smallpox did not respect borders
carbon dioxide also blows right across
borders
nuclear winter doesn't respect borders
so many of these great challenges
are truly global challenges and and
taking them on
we can we can be inspired by this
audacity that we've seen
in um
today's guest of honor here bill feige
and and victor donna
tony what about you if you were to pick
out a few moonshots they're truly
audacious that you would like us to to
take on
ideally again as global collaborations
what's on your
top list
you know max there are a couple there
there are finishing
um
things that have been started that are
still doable i'm very frustrated as an
infectious disease person
that we have not yet
eradicated two diseases that are
eminently eradicatable
and that is polio we were almost there
almost and then we slipped a bit as a as
a global community but i think we can
get back on track
and do polio
the other
is the common disease of measles
you know um i learned from bill
many years ago from things he's written
that there's
control there's elimination and there's
eradication
you know and we've controlled and
eliminated to many respects measles for
example in many of the developing
countries but we have not yet eradicated
it
but it is eminently eradicatable and i
think we need to continue
to not give up on that effort so those
are two of the things that i think we
need to aim at
the other is something that is also you
know audacious and bold
but it's something we should not
give up on is that to have throughout
the world
health systems
that are
achievable and available to everyone
throughout the world i mean if we could
build up
local global health systems so that
people in developing countries do not
suffer
and in some cases die
from diseases that are so easily taken
care of
in the developed world i you know i just
have felt always
that we have a moral responsibility
those of us who live in rich countries
to share that wealth in the sense of
providing for developing countries some
of the things that's impossible for them
to do on their own
you don't want to make welfare states of
everyone but you got to help people to
do things that they can't do on their
own
so those are three things that i think
we can look forward to in the coming
decades that's very inspiring the thing
you said there about helping the
developing world of course also is a is
a great way to celebrate the
victor donovan bill feige because of
course the rich countries had already
been vaccinating their populations for
quite a while and it was the the final
amazing push was precisely to help the
rest of the world
get up to that same level and
maybe
if if you could also just say a couple
of words to help those who are listening
here understand why it was even though
people who are listening they've heard
of so many diseases and they might
wonder why are you picking just measles
and polio you want to say something
about the human-only transmission
yeah all right
well that's a very good point mac max
there are certain characteristics that
you have to have
if you want to eradicate uh an
infectious disease from the planet
and if it has a reservoir in another
species
it becomes extremely difficult if not
impossible
to do which is one of the reasons why
a disease like ebola may be very
difficult to do because there are
reservoirs all over the place with ebola
particularly in central in central
africa the other thing is the ingredient
that you have a highly efficacious and
effective vaccine
and that's what we have for both of them
the measles vaccine is the gold standard
of efficacy it's about 98
effective you achieve hurt immunity
by getting 90 or more of the population
vaccinated
once you do that
measles will disappear and the same
holds true for polio
thank you so much
let me ask uh
also you michael and
you bill if michael do you have any any
moonshots any really audacious things
you would like to see
yeah i actually wanted to ask tony
about
about coronavirus
because he mentioned that
lack of animal reservoir for those
polio and
and
measles
is a kind of
factor that allows elimination but what
about coronavirus which has a very wide
reservoir animal reservoir can we
eliminate that one i think michael that
we can for the following reason
that i believe given what we know of the
commonality of spike proteins which are
the major antigen or immunogen in a
vaccine
for coronaviruses
that it is attainable for us to develop
what we call a universal coronavirus
vaccine
namely a vaccine that is not only
effective against the common cold
coronaviruses of which there are four
effective against the three known
pandemic coronaviruses sars mares and
now sars coronavirus ii
but any coronavirus that might actually
emerge in the future because there is a
large bat reservoir for coronaviruses
but if you can vaccinate the world
with a universal coronavirus vaccine you
could even prevent it eva from becoming
a public health hazard
thank you
michael you are a very successful
researcher yourself
on hiv
so do you think there might be any hope
one day of also making hiv extinct
um yeah i was actually waiting for tony
to
to mention it but
he didn't and uh
i agree that that may be a long shot
that it's really a very
difficult uh task uh simply because hiv
is a chronic disease it's kind of it's
very difficult to but i believe that uh
if we um if we kind of
use the technology
and in particular this jennifer's kind
of crispr
uh based
technology to
uh
which would allow us to
really eliminate the virus from the
from the infected people and uh
eventually i think
it's it would be possible to
uh to
get uh this uh infection from the human
population of course this virus again it
it exists in in animals and in in in
monkeys
so but
but
maybe
at some day we will have a vaccine that
again
would prevent
transmission and infection so i i
i think that
hiv
can can be added to this future
kind of hopes uh of uh
elimination of infectious diseases
wonderful and in about one minute uh
we're gonna do uh
what
in soccer is called a substitution we're
gonna let
anthony fauci go off and
continue helping us with you know what
and replace him with another awesome
panelist but i want to
first give you a chance
anthony to get the last word in this
segment here is there anything more you
want to add
oh yes i i i want to just express my
appreciation for giving me the
opportunity to participate
uh over this uh hour 45 minutes with two
extraordinary heroes
in a uh
in an arena in which i work every single
day i mean
there's something about
having heroes that you can look up to
and certainly uh victor and bill are two
of those individuals also to have the
opportunity to be on the panel with with
jennifer and to congratulate her again
on an extraordinary accomplishment for
which she was so deservedly awarded the
nobel prize yesterday
well thank you and as you heard you
yourself are of course also a hero who's
inspired so many here so thank you so
much and and
keep doing with what you do so well and
don't let all the noise get to you
thank you very much so much tony what a
real pleasure bye-bye and now
we will welcome to this conversation
none other than professor matthew
messelson
from harvard university last year's
future life award winner who as i'm hey
matthew so great to see you
i think you need to unmute yourself
there
and uh
if i'm half as energetic at 60
you are i know
i'll be i'll be really delighted it's
such a pleasure to have you with us
can you hear me loud and clear very good
i should explain why i'm wearing this
mask
it's because dentistry has caused a very
temporary hematoma which i don't want
you to have to suffer to see
otherwise it's a trivial thing but i do
need to wear the mask to protect you
there is something i would like to say i
don't know if this is the right time max
i don't want to intrude on other things
no please do please do all right so
there's certainly justifiable concern
for what are called existential threats
that involve
mass destruction of environment or of
human life
it also for
threats that uh
might occur in the near future
but it's very difficult to think
productively about things that might
happen
in the distant future or things that
happen or accrue only very gradually we
all know that we're evolved to deal with
imminent threats
uh but not to deal very well with
long-term threats
so the thing i want to mention
is that
not only is it important to protect
human life
what you are celebrating today
but it's also important to think about
because i don't know how to do it yet
to protect what it means to be human
what it means to be in other words to
protect our humanity
one could imagine
that our species in some evolved form
because
evolution is not stopping it's
proceeding
with some manifestation of our species
or a species that might in a long period
of time branch off from it
would be thriving very healthy
in a very nice environment but would
have lost some of the attributes that we
value most
how do you deal with this kind of a
question
i hardly know
one of the things would be first to just
discuss
and particularly with students because
they're the people who will be in
positions to influence
the
dialogue of the future and
decisions of the future to discuss what
do we value most
in humanity is it curiosity
is it kindness
is it compassion
is it the ability to sit down
purely with mathematical concepts
develop them and then find out
for everyone's astonishment that they
tell you
what the physical world is like
that's what einstein is just one example
did he sat down
and worked with what are called tensors
and other mathematical
formulations following the rules of the
mass
and got general relativity
and now we detect
uh
signals from gravitational waves caused
by black holes
colliding
so what uh maybe there are other things
so i know i have however i am worried
about one thing
and this is in jennifer's promise of
course
and that is not today not tomorrow not
in any of our lifetimes but if it ever
becomes common practice
to manipulate the human genome
which i'm sure will happen
i hope that when it does happen
we know enough about something with
regard to which we know nothing now
which is what is it inside of this box
that makes us human
yeah thank you so much for this perfect
perfect uh
i wanted to say one more thing about
that
and that is that i know enough about
this to know that off target effects
are not going to be a serious problem
that can be dealt with
i am concerned and this is directed to
jennifer
with epistatic interactions
because we know almost nothing
about
i don't want to get too technical here
i've written about it
but we know almost nothing about how the
product of one gene
interacts with the products of other
genes
so that in modifying the product of one
gene
an ignorance of how it might interact
with other genes
which is called epistasis
uh who knows exactly what kind of deep
waters might get into so there needs to
be more study of the humanities more
asking what makes us human eventually
we'll know up here it's all up here got
to be there
so that uh not only
modification of the human genome but
also possibly if we uh
if we enter if we entrust
too much of our humanity to machines
i mean advanced intelligent machines
if we do too much in trusting
i would call it entrusting because in
principle we should always have the
ability to pull it back
but that too might have long-term
effects on
what it means to be human yeah matthew
let me jump in here matthew and thank
you so much again for first segueing
into exactly what we want to focus the
remainder of this conversation on and
before we we hear
from about epistemic interactions
from from jennifer and so on
just to frame this at the higher level
what we want to focus on is exactly this
looking farther into the future now
biotechnology and so on will obviously
continue growing ever more powerful
how can we steer it
in a good direction towards great uses
like eradicating smallpox and the other
diseases that we heard about earlier
and away from bad uses
such as humanity
let me just finish here
like biological weapons
that you helped us get banned
and and other things so
i wanted to first first ask you here
jennifer so you you in terms of this
steering challenge now
you wrote this very interesting piece in
the economist recently where
you actually made some quite concrete
proposals for what we should do do you
want to
do you want to share a little bit about
that with the rest of us
well i i certainly agree with what matt
meselson just articulated we absolutely
need to be thinking about how to
integrate science with a broader
perspective on what it means to be human
and how do we do that it's a big
challenge
i personally think that it has to
involve all of us
who are practicing scientists being a
lot more engaged than we maybe have been
in the past in these conversations and
you know i saw an interesting twitter
thread this morning that
reflected i think what
many people unfortunately uh think of
scientists which is not flattering
and uh you know they think about
scientists as uh people who are are a
bit smug maybe a bit um
you know self-involved and and not
inclusive
in our views of the world and our our
incorporation of other you know other
sort of non-uh non-scientists in
thinking about the future of science and
technology so
i'd really like to see that become a
much more commonplace thing i think it
was true in the in the past historically
that science was far more integrated
into
society and you know dinner table
conversations than maybe it is now so
i think we all have a part to play there
and uh and i think also as matt meselson
said i agree that it has to it has to be
the
uh the focus of our our students they
are the future and they're the future of
everything and so we really need to
encourage our students to be
more inclusive in their thinking
rather than getting too siloed in
particular areas of science thinking
about it in a more integrated way and it
is a big challenge but i think that's
something that honestly the future of
life institute
is well positioned to do
thank you for that yeah this is of
course the whole reason we created the
future of life institute because
we love technology
but technology is not
good it's also not evil it's a tool and
we want to work to steer it towards good
uses like eradicating smallpox and away
from the ones that you matthew have
worked so hard to to
put the kibosh on and i want to just
give a shout out here to victor john of
himself also because the book
that has never been read in english
before that we had translated and is on
the website now my wife and i
had a lot of fun reading it just over
the past few nights here and
it was so touching to see that
he was very much a soviet version of
matthew meselson in in 1916 in 1968 he
spent two months
learning spanish
just so he could go to a conference in
mexico and give a speech in spanish
about why we should ban bioweapons
it was really remarkable and uh
in uh and then much much later
he when he discovered to his horror you
can read about this again in this book
which we can download for free
that his deputy and his institute that
he ran had secretly been developing
bioweapons behind his back he
immediately fired him and made a big
stink about it and uh
he this was clearly something he was
very very very
passionate about i want to ask you bill
a little bit also
the same question if you think about the
future
all the great things that we can do with
biology and biotech and
the things we should avoid what are the
things you feel most strongly we have to
be careful to avoid and do you have any
any recommendations for how we can keep
our moral compass
working
thank you max first i would repeat some
of the things that we heard i think the
biggest problems that we face are
problems that would lead to the
extinction of humans
and there are three or four big ones
we've heard a little bit about each one
but global warming is one nuclear
weapons is the second one artificial
intelligence i think is a third one and
i think synthetic biology is a fourth
one so we should be putting a lot of
attention
on the things that could actually cause
the extinction
of humans
a second area that i would think about
is this area that tony brought up of
equity
and
twine be the historian
said the 20th century
will be remembered for the time when we
got equity in health around the world he
was absolutely wrong
we ended the century with such a gap
but
i think we now have tools
we have the ability to narrow that gap
so equity
in various things health would be one
education would be another
the ability
for people to thrive
so that's an area and then i would go to
the third area that tony was talking
about
there are specific diseases that we
could eliminate right now and i agree
with him that
polio and
measles are two of them
a guinea worm is close to eradication
but without a vaccine
so we shouldn't limit eradication to
infectious diseases i think we should be
thinking about chemicals and other
things that are harmful and how would we
eradicate them
i think the future in this
is very difficult because of what we
call asymmetry that it's possible for a
person or a small group of people
to actually hold an entire country or
the entire world at hostage with their
science and technology
and so on the one hand i think continue
to reward people who are using science
and technology correctly
and then we need a real surveillance
system to detect
when people are doing something that
could cause great harm to to lots of
people
but i take some comfort from how we see
this happening in crime
it's very difficult for people to do
certain things now without being filmed
and
so i think we're getting better at
surveillance but we're not perfect in
surveillance
but to reward the people that are doing
it right it's something we should
continue doing and that's of course what
the institute is doing this remark you
made there about how
cheaper
and cheaper and more accessible powerful
tech in the hands of people who for
whatever reason have a grudge can be
very dangerous that
that echoes so beautifully
what you
matthew once took once told me was the
key argument you made when you convinced
henry kissinger and richard nixon to ban
bioweapons about cheap cheap weapons you
want to share that with
with the whole group here
how you persuaded them what happened
completely by accident
not in the case of victors donov who did
this by will in my case it was accident
i was working for the government in the
summer of 1963 and i was given a tour of
fort dietrich and we came to a big
building which had a 10 000 liter
fermenter and i asked my guide a very
nice man what do we do there and he said
we make anthrax spores
and i asked him why do we need that and
he said
it's cheaper than nuclear weapons it's a
strategic weapon that much cheaper we
can save a lot of money
and i took a taxi cab to get back to my
office in the state department and it
dawned on me wait
we don't want to have 10 cent nuclear
weapons why would we want to have cheap
biological weapons if they're so
potentially potent
i got back to my office my office mate
was freeman dyson who i had taken my
first quantum mechanics for and he gave
me great encouragement which was very so
i resolved that i made a protocol like
the way we do in the laboratory what
would be needed to get rid of this
program
and the answer was only the president
could do it so what's how do you get to
him and then you write the details of
the protocol and i spent the next 10
years just following the protocol but
since i was fortunate enough
to be at harvard and to have an
administration that was still affected
by jack kennedy's presidency from
harvard
i was able to talk to anybody whose door
i knocked on
and little by little everybody came to
see we don't want to pioneer a cheap
weapon of mass destruction we want more
to be so expensive that nobody could
afford it but certainly not for
everybody to be able to afford it
that's that's that's it that's such a
but you can't do that with other
problems
this is a very special case
so for those of you who just joined now
you can really understand why matthew
meselson got
last year's future of life award and
we're so grateful to you you're a true
hero for us all and we're going to say
something about vaccines it's certainly
important to have good vaccines for
certain things but don't forget the
vector we don't have black death anymore
we don't have a vaccination against
pastorella pestis we just don't have a
lot of rats and lice
so it's important to control the rats
and the lice and the mosquitoes etc etc
and even the air we breathe
in the case of things that are
transmitted as aerosols all of those
things can be done by a kind of
engineering but that's not vaccines
although vaccines are important but a
very expensive way to go
thank you thank you so much matt now
continuing on this this theme here about
things we might worry about
you you jennifer
are you
i can't see you anymore are you still
here i'm sorry jennifer i had to go max
i apologize
oh okay okay great
so this is uh
so staying on this on this theme here of
of how how we can steer this technology
towards um
good uses we um
you've mentioned something we need to
worry about a lot which is the
technology getting both very powerful
and then
being very cheap and falling into the
wrong hands
um and you also so i'm curious what
concrete things
what concrete advice would you give to
any um
political leaders or other other
influential folks
about what we can do right now
to push things in in the right direction
would you like to have more oversight
of what's happening
every political leader should find him
or herself
a group of at least two or three good
scientists
to be by their elbow whenever they need
them they should get bill feige to be
for example whoever is the president 10
years from now
should have a small
quarterly of good scientists who are
also good friends who can be called up
on the phone at any time that one step
would get a lot accomplished
wonderful
since uh
since viktor zhanov
cannot be with us today and speak with
his own voice today i'm very curious if
for example you michael have any
anecdotes about your father that you
would you would like to share with us to
make it a little bit more personal
so we can all
help us all get to know him
um
well uh
yes there the there was a lot of
anecdotes
uh but uh he i i should say immediately
that
that
in his uh
in his personal life he didn't really
talk too much about
smallpox eradication or
other kind of accomplishments that he
had
with us the family he
he kind of left it to his
uh
his kind of
research and i mean he was always
involved in in science in researching
in uh
reading papers writing books and all
these things
and
basically the only
thing that
we heard as a family about uh about his
his kind of efforts to
to eradicate diseases fight diseases and
things like that
was when he invited friends and
and
visitors and colleagues to our house
our
apartment
and they were kind of
discussing it and then we as a family
could hear that and in this respect i
just uh remember
uh
there was a
visit from the american
delegation and it included
a lot of uh famous uh
scientists uh and uh i believe uh howard
thurman was was there
uh at that time and uh
a lot of other
kind of people i didn't know
i only heard of them later on when i
developed as a
researcher so
and they were
kind of uh talking about
viruses and
and
basically and at that time i i just
remember that
they were discussing the
how the viruses can
can become a part of of a
human kind of body and it was obvious
for retroviruses of course but but
victor
was very uh kind of interested in in
he was kind of proposing this idea that
this can can happen with other viruses
as well
that they can become part of
of
their
human
cells and affect our
kind of immunity and other things and i
believe that that's a
very interesting idea that never was
fully developed and i believe that now
people come to
to
kind of think about that more and more
thank you so much for sharing that then
speaking of anecdotes um
bill
do you want to share with people with
our listeners here also the the story
about that amazing dinner which i
thought really drove home and the
all the
the richness of the international
u.s soviet collaboration
yes thank you max
victor came for a week to visit us at
cdc
along with dr benedictoff
and the two of them spent the entire
week going program by program at cdc
they found it so interesting always
asking questions taking notes
on the last night in atlanta
we put out a dinner for them at stone
mountain
and the state department required
the state
officers to actually come to atlanta
because these were such important
visitors benedict off and victor
so they sent two people from the state
department
they sent down the surgeon general
julius richmond
and so we had a nice dinner after dinner
i got up and i proposed some toasts the
first toast that i proposed was
i would like to toast the soviet army
and with that the state department
people
absolutely lost all the blood in their
face and they sat there not knowing
what's going to happen next
and both benedictof and victor
looked uneasy what's coming next
and the only person that was sanguine
was julius richmond the surgeon general
he didn't know what i was going to say
but he was okay with whatever i said
so i said
that i would toast the soviet army
because
the person at the table who was the
deputy director at cdc bill watson
had been in a pow camp during the second
world war
and he had watched the destruction of
german cities
he was very
emotionally involved in this and then he
was liberated by the soviet army
and i pointed out what this meant to the
health of americans what it meant to the
health of people in the world
and everybody breathed a sigh of relief
and i remember
benedictoff then getting up and saying
i couldn't make a toast like that
without you having done it first but he
said
now i'm going to tell you what i would
tell pravda and uh so he then told a
similar story but it was a very nice
night and it it was actually a
demonstration of what happened in this
program
with soviets and americans working side
by side
and in india i actually supervised
soviets who in turn supervised americans
now you can't imagine that happening
during the cold war in other any other
program
but it shows what's possible in health
and it says to me we should figure out
how to exploit this
how to use health problems
as surrogates for an alien invasion
that it just we all have to be involved
in finding the solutions
thank you for that now we know that uh
you bill have not only a very big brain
and a very big heart but also a very
equally big sense of humor
and uh it's so great to hear you talk
about international collaboration that
is best here
today because looking here in the chat
we have people listening right now
from china
from russia from romania the uk sweden
canada norway
austria
italy new zealand and as far away and
azerbaijan and other places so
hopefully this is also something we can
learn from again if it could be done
then
it can probably be done again and bill
we have another question here directly
from our live audience which is
specifically directed at you they're
wondering how did you get into smallpox
in the first place
well the
uh i was with the epidemic intelligence
service at cdc
and i was stationed in denver colorado
i got a call one noon
saying that there was a suspected case
of smallpox in a child
in the navajo nation in new mexico
and that they'd already made a
reservation on a plane for me to fly
there that evening
and they suggested i get a book written
by dixon on smallpox
so i went to the medical library found
out it was checked out to a medical
student
who was writing a paper on smallpox
i was able to find him
and he did not want to give up the book
because he was writing a paper and it
took some real political
persuasion to get that book out of his
hands
but i
quickly went through the relevant parts
of it
so that i felt i knew the difference
between chickenpox and smallpox anyway
not on that plane
and i was totally uh surprised to find
that there was a
car that drove right to the plane as it
stopped before we got to the terminal
and they had me get off as they took me
to the hospital
and then i found that there were people
waiting at the hospital for the quotes
outside expert on smallpox
to examine the child
and as i entered that room
i knew from the door before i ever got
to the bedside that i had no idea what
that child had
and it turned out to be a very confusing
situation
of a child recovering from measles and
then having disseminated herpes on top
of that
and then to make it worse it's one of
only two errors that i have known about
in smallpox lab work at cdc
where they originally diagnosed it as
compatible with smallpox so we went
through some difficult days
but it
piqued my interest and the next year i
went to india as part of a cdc project
and saw smallpox for the first time and
i was
impressed with what a terrible disease
this is
as i saw even the workers at the
hospital
were reluctant
to touch the patient and he realized how
those patients felt now alienated from
the world
so that even if they recovered and they
had pock marks that's the feeling they
were going to have is that they were
alienated
from the world so it turned out to be
an emotional thing with me of being
interested in smallpox because of that
first case
eventually
i i
read in your book also though you got so
good at diagnosing small pox at a glance
that you couldn't even help yourself
from
look
by seeing people's pock marks as you
walk through the streets of india and
other places and there was a very
emotional thing you mentioned there
about how that
evolved over the years
do you want to share that
well over the years i came to realize
you could actually smell smallpox before
you entered the room
and so if i would be starting now with
smallpox eradication
one of the first things i would do is
train dogs
because they would be able to pick this
up much faster than humans
if i would be starting now on smallpox
eradication i probably wouldn't be
because as michael knows
that with hiv it changed everything we
actually eradicated smallpox during a
window of opportunity
and if we had waited until hiv came
along we would have had immune problems
that would have made it difficult to do
the kind of vaccination programs we did
fantastic
so we're soon going to give our guests
of honor here the last word let me
say something in closing
before we do that though i i want to
this is a very bad habit that professors
have
can't
help assigning homework this is homework
for all of you out there listening to
this
your homework the way you can contribute
is by letting us know who should get the
future life award in the future
don't worry
if you're not completely sure we take
all the nominations and subject them to
very careful scientific scrutiny and so
on but if you nominate next year's
winner you know we will give you
three thousand dollars just as a token
of appreciation
and
the uh
and if you tell someone else about this
and then they nominate the winner you
will give them we'll give you 1500 and
then 3 000 so we want to really crowd
source and get all the good ideas
because some of the greatest heroes out
there i believe are so unsung that
almost nobody has heard about them um
i also want to before we give you all
the last word here say some word of
thanks
first of all again to yon talin
friend and co-founder of the future life
institute and also
the very generous guy thanks to whom
we're actually able to give you prize
money thank you yan
you're amazing i also want to thank the
amazing team here at the future life
institute who has worked very hard for a
very long time to make all this possible
beaming love and appreciation
at you all
and now
and
finally for the rest of you who are
listening to this if you would like to
hear a little bit more or learn a bit
more about our great heroes please go to
futurelife.org and go to the page about
this award
you will find there a fascinating
podcast
that lucas perry has recorded
with really interesting interviews with
all of the winners here today
you will find this uh never previously
existing in english book about victor
janov
you'll find links to bill's amazing book
and so on this is a journey that can
continue for a long time but for now let
me uh
turn to
first of all
victor's jones jr do you want to say a
few words
just couple words
regarding this rewards
well um i'm really proud
um
want to say to how much i'm proud to get
this award for my father
and unfortunately i was very young in
the time
my father was working on this smallpox
eradication
and often had no time even for me and
for my brother but
now i understand that it was to save
millions of lives
and i wanna say thank you very much i'm
very proud to take this award for my
father and thank you again
and thank you thank you for continuing
the
legacy there and um michael
do you want to say a few words
yes i want to join uh my brother and uh
thank the future of life institute
and especially uh for your
kind of
recognition of victor donov's lifelong
efforts to engage international
cooperation in fighting world diseases
and i think that that's the key point to
our future uh success in fighting
infections
thank you so much and uh bill you're
going to get the last word for this live
stream
thank you max first i
to have a professor assign homework
uh reminds me that when i gave a
commencement address at a college once
i said why do we have commencement
addresses
because the passion to teach surpasses
the passion to learn
and so teachers will give you homework
right till the end
but
let me say that
i i'm so pleased with this award but i'm
particularly pleased that you've made it
international made the point that this
was international and that it was
possible because of a problem
that politics could not interfere with
so even in the cold war
we had the soviets and the americans
working together
it becomes a great example of how we
should do things in the future thank you
so much
what a great way to summarize what this
is all about
thank you so much all of you
huge congratulations to our winners
and i hope
all of you who are listening feel
inspired by this and go out and do great
things to make a great future of life
thank you
goodbye
you